Weak little one cutter Summer world
Spinach Hi I've stood on the stage burning right as the leader of Fran I'll burn
100 million by right and stand on the stage so I can be Sarah's leader from now
on  No matter where I am, my hot soul
can see my ears
Look at the Imari Kouranosaki breakwater lighthouse, Lina
Then listen to me
Watch the windy day
5 case
[music]
tl i bwan w
ana
nan
[music]
car
give
dan
uh
[music]
[applause]
rar
[music]
[applause]
starting this week  It's time to end it because it's the sex of the flash seed
If you feel anxious or lonely, come back here
anytime We haven't gone,
we're in Suwa, so
don't worry Hey, close your ears
Seems like kelp c
[music]
Sex is always the answer you're looking for
[applause]
[music]